Speaker 1: All right. This is very serious stuff.
The Donald Trump rape trial is underway in New
York, and it is not getting nearly the attention
that it likely deserves. We're going to go over a
few of the headlines, a few of the articles, but
this is very serious stuff and very graphic stuff
is happening in this trial. The Guardian has
an article. Donald Trump Raped Me. Writer Jean
Carroll testifies in New York court. This is now
under oath in court. Advice columnist says former
president, quote, shattered my reputation and says
alleged attack left her unable to enjoy a romantic
life. Carroll testified in her civil lawsuit
seeking damages for battery after Trump allegedly
sexually assaulted her in a New York Department
store changing room in 1996 and for defamation
after he accused her of lying and perpetrating
a hoax when she went public with her accusations
in a book, quote, under oath to the jury from
Jean Carroll. And there are no cameras in the
courtroom. So while we have these reports, quote,
I'm here because Donald Trump raped me. And when
I wrote about it, he said it didn't happen. He
lied and shattered my reputation. I'm here to try
and get my life back. Before Carroll testified,
Judge Louis Kaplan warned Trump may have crossed
the line into jury tampering after the former
president posted an attack on a social media
site. Truth, Social Calling Carol's accusations a
made up scam and a witch hunt. We're going to look
at those posts in a moment. A Politico article
also explains the details of the alleged event.
Carroll, a magazine columnist, has accused Trump
of sexually assaulting her in a dressing room of
luxury department store Bergdorf Goodman in the
mid-nineties. And then, indeed, there is a Yahoo
News article from Yahoo News Canada, which goes
into the graphic detail that Jean Carroll revealed
under oath, talking about the sixth floor lingerie
department, a lacy bodysuit that Trump jokingly
suggested she try on. And it includes all sorts
of graphic details that I don't know that I
necessarily need to go into. But they are they
are quite violent. Now, Donald Trump's reaction
to this, he went on truths, social.
Speaker 3: Truth, essential.
Speaker 1: And he posted the following. These
are the posts that could be considered tampering.
Quote The Gene Carroll case is Bergdorf Goodman
is a made up scam. Her lawyer is a political
operative financed by a big political donor that
they said didn't exist, only to get caught lying
about that. Just look at her CNN interview before
and after the commercial break like a different
person. She said there was a dress using the old
Monica Lewinsky stuff. Then she didn't want to
produce it. The dress should be allowed to be part
of the case. This is a fraudulent and false story
witch hunt. Then continuing in a second post to
troth quote, They got caught lying. The Miss Berg
going from Miz to Miss Bergdorf Goodman case is
financed by a big political donor that they tried
to hide. Does anybody believe that I would take a
then almost 60 year old woman that I didn't know
from the front door of a very crowded department
store with me being very well known, to put it
mildly, into a tiny dressing room. And her, she
didn't scream. There are no witnesses. Nobody
saw this. She never made a police complaint. If I
was seen there with a woman. Big press scam. Now,
aside from the facts of this case, which
are slowly being asserted in court,
this is not even close to the only sexual
assault allegation against Donald Trump. Not
by a long shot. We're talking about dozens of such
allegations, including from one of Donald Trump's
own ex-wives. Now, we could mention many of them,
but one particular allegation of note relates to
a lawsuit filed in 2016 by a woman under the name
Jane Doe against Donald Trump, which accused Trump
of raping her when she was 13 years old in 1994.
This lawsuit, which I've mentioned to you before,
was filed in New York. It was dismissed in 2017 by
a judge who said the allegations aren't specific
enough and the accuser later withdrew the lawsuit,
reportedly because of the threats to her and her
family's safety. Trump, of course, has repeatedly
denied those allegations and has said that they
are, quote, false and ridiculous. So where is
the Green Carol case going? Remember, there
are two parts to this. There's the defamation
allegation against Trump. There is also the actual
assault allegation which can be brought despite
traditional statutes of limitations, because of a
particular New York law that says if you didn't,
which opens up a window for filing such cases,
even if the statute of limitations has expired,
if you didn't previously bring the allegation
forward, I have no idea in the world what is
going to happen with this case. There were
questions about whether Trump would even be in
the courtroom. So far, he has not been. He has
an event in New Hampshire later today which
we will cover live, which certainly puts him
closer to New York than Florida does. But at this
point, no indication that he plans to be there